molti la chiamano scossa per altri
rappresenta la forza di un fulmine
o banalmente le utenze di casa
l'elettricità è molto di più è la forza
motrice che ci permette di camminare di
mangiare di pensare e addirittura di
emozionarci e proprio così
le cellule del nostro cervello e neuroni
comunicano in network estremamente
complessi fatti di miliardi di
connessioni attraverso proprio impulsi
elettrici che si chiamano potenziali
d'azione
ora potete ben immaginare che poter
decodificare questo tipo di informazioni
è sicuramente un processo molto
complesso
la bioelettronica è una disciplina che
ci permette di costruire delle
piattaforme capaci di monitorare
registrare questi potenziali d'azione da
un network di neuroni come quello che
vedete giusto per darvi un'idea un
simbolo corpo neuronale a come diametro
un terzo di un vostro capello
siamo in grado di costruire questo tipo
di gatta forme in maniera estremamente
miniaturizzata nanotecnologie micro
tecnologie le chiamano il primo esempio
è stato quello di un nerone sopra un
transistor di silicio immaginiamo però
per un attimo di fare il processo
inverso e cioè di pensare a mettere
all'interno del nostro corpo un chip
la prima cosa a cui in genere io penso è
quella di un cyborg attivissimo che nei
film ci fa sempre vedere che può
distruggere il mondo
beh diciamo che questo tipo di
componente artificiale che con poi
riprendere quelle che sono le
caratteristiche umane è un tema
abbastanza ricorrente no nella storia
della tecnologia addirittura leonardo
già se ne parlava con un automa
mi piace pensare invece di avere un
elemento totalmente artificiale di
averne solamente una parte e di poterla
mettere all'interno del nostro corpo
umano per poter ripristinare o
potenziare delle funzionalità che sono
state perse per esempio proprio nel
cervello quello che infatti noi proviamo
a fare è quello di mettere dei microchip
all'interno del cervello e andare
proprio a decodificare il flusso di
informazioni la consistenza del cervello
è veramente molto simile
a quella di un budino io personalmente
quando devo mangiare un budino non ce la
faccio perché soligo il cucchiaio e alla
fine mi scoccio pensate allora di dover
mettere un microchip all'interno di un
budino una cosa estremamente difficile
c'è ancora un'altra particolarità le
superficie di questi dispositivi che
sono a contatto con le cellule sono
estremamente piatti piatte come questo
pavimento le cellule sono molto
intelligenti e ahimé non gli piace per
niente essere su questo tipo di
superfici stanno lì che scivola non
sanno neanche dove aggrapparsi quello
che abbiamo capito negli ultimi anni e
che invece quando mettiamo su queste
superfici dei piloncini che fuoriescono
ecco le cellule piace particolarmente si
aggrappano stanno lì ed è come se
provassero ad abbracciarli vedete in
questo caso una cellula cardiaca che sta
appunto su un tappeto di queste
strutture ci può stare per lungo tempo
quello che succede che quando vogliamo
registrare l'attività elettrica vogliamo
stimolare le cellule con degli impulsi
elettrici
in questo modo lo facciamo in maniera
estremamente efficiente perché le
cellule sono molto vicine agli elettrodi
con il mio giovane gruppo di ricerca a
napoli da un anno e mezzo stiamo
provando ad estendere questo concetto di
stimolazione tramite impulsi elettrici
non solo alle cellule come i neuroni o
le cellule cardiache che sono
intrinsecamente già elettriche ma anche
ad altre cellule di altri organi che
generalmente elettriche non sono come
per esempio la pelle lavoriamo ad un
progetto che noi chiamiamo il cerotto
solare immaginate di avere un taglio una
ferita da taglio o bruciatura in genere
ci mettete un cerotto avete un processo
infiammatorio che e subito parte appena
avete questo tipo di problema ora il
processo infiammatorio aimeri non
permette alle cellule buon e della pelle
i fibroblasti tirati nociti di
rigenerarsi o comunque dire generarsi
molto lentamente
quello che noi pensiamo invece che dando
piccole scariche direttamente dove c'è
la ferita siamo in grado di rigenerare
la pelle più velocemente
ora immaginate che questa cosa si può
fare con una
un elettrodo avrebbe bisogno di una
batteria per essere alimentato andreste
mai in giro con una grande batteria
addosso non penso non sarebbe una cosa
troppo conveniente allora quello che noi
abbiamo pensato e di creare un bendaggio
che intrinsecamente possa generare
energia da dove dalla luce un pannello
solare è proprio quello che ne
utilizziamo esattamente come quelli che
avete sulle vostre case casomai però se
ci pensate quelli sono estremamente
rigidi un bendaggio deve essere
flessibile deve essere biocompatibile ve
lo mettereste mai un pannello solare sul
braccio io personalmente no
esistono però delle plastiche che sono
diciamo intelligenti
in genere le plastiche sono isolanti noi
possiamo renderle conduttive e renderle
proprio flessibili in maniera tale da
ricreare esattamente un bendaggio ora ma
perché un impulso elettrico è in grado
di rigenerare una cellula della pelle
allora ricordiamoci sempre il principio
del piloncino l'elettro della cella
solare del bendaggio in contatto con le
cellule della pelle sarà fatto
esattamente così come un piccolo
cilindro ora quando un campo
elettromagnetico viene applicato appunto
in prossimità di una cellula della pelle
succede una cosa molto interessante gli
ioni di calcio che sono all'esterno
della cellula
cominciano ad entrare sono facilitati
proprio dalla presenza di questo campo
elettrico
ora la concentrazione di calcio
all'interno della cellula far aumentata
e questo non fa altro che andare a
attivare delle proteine e questo tipo di
proteina è il responsabile della
proliferazione delle cellule quindi più
calcio faccio entrare più avrò
poliferazione no ahimè dobbiamo ancora
capire qual è il tipo di stimolazione
adatta quindi quanta scarica elettrica
dobbiamo dare ad una cellula per poter
la falla proliferare più velocemente il
microchip nel cervello
il cerotto solare sono due esempi che ci
permettono di capire quanto le micro e
le nanotecnologie
si stanno sempre di più integrando non
solo nel nostro corpo ma proprio della
nostra vita
la domanda che ci dobbiamo fare è
sicuramente per il futuro
questi tipi di dispositivi diventeranno
sempre più piccoli quasi invisibile ma
sempre più efficaci e saranno in grado
di ripristinare e potenziare sempre di
più
molte delle nostre funzioni alla fine
quello che mi piace immaginare non è più
l'immagine cattiva del cyborg che
distrugge tutto ma che noi in un futuro
e diventeremo un po alla fine dei cyborg
ma stavolta buoni grazie
[Applauso]